Michael klampt ist bei uns er lebt gut
auch ohne Arbeit nennt sich selbst den
faulsten Deutschland wir haben einen
Mann hier am Tisch sitzen der schon
lange nicht mehr arbeitet für den das
nicht erlebensinhalt ist Michael klampt
ist bei uns der sich selbst den faulsten
deutschen nennt so darf ich das sagen
weil sich selber eben von sich sagen
seit wann arbeiten sie nicht mehr ja ich
arbeite natürlich also jetzt überhaupt
nicht mehr arbeiten tue ich jetzt seit
2020 aber bei mir hat das schon recht
früh angefangen und das ist vielleicht
auch der Unterschied zwischen den Herren
hier am Tisch ja der alle eine Karriere
gemacht haben nicht wollte das nicht ja
also wenn sich vorstellen mit 16 Jahren
alle möchten ein tolles Abitur machen
was tolles lernen was tolles werden ich
wollte das nicht ganz einfach deshalb
weil es mir meine Lebenszeit wegnimmt ja
ich hatte ich hatte keine Motivation für
eine Karriere meine Lebenszeit zu opfern
und jetzt bin ich habe ja schon gewisses
Alter bin ich sehr froh dass ich so
gemacht habe denn ich kann zurückschauen
und kann sagen es war ein tolle Leben es
war eine entspanntes Leben ein schönes
Leben und ich mache es nicht erst wenn
es später ist sie haben noch zehn Jahre
wenn wir in arbeitsbiografien denken was
sie nicht tun dann hätten sie noch zehn
Jahre Arbeit sozusagen vor sich sind 57
das darf ich einmal sagen was machen Sie
den ganzen Tag ja das sind gute Frage
momentan bin ich ja gerade beim
Arbeitsamt und da kommen wir auch gerade
kurz zum Bürgergeld wenn ich das kurz
sagen darf wir reden ja über das
Bürgergeld aber wir müssen vielleicht
mal an diese Bürger denken denen das
total wird ja ich glaube wir sind einmal
noch mal ganz kurz bleiben und dann
diskutieren wir auch mit ihm wir wollen
Sie einmal kennenlernen also was wovon
leben sie aktuell leben sie von vom
Sozialstaat nein ich lebe nicht von
sozial-stadt ich habe früher im
Tourismus gearbeitet also ich war fünf
Jahre auf Kreuzfahrt habe sechs
Weltreisen gemacht es waren angenehme
Jobs sozusagen sehr angenehme Jobs habe
ich auch für gesorgt dass das angenehm
ist sonst hätte ich es nicht gemacht und
ich war auch
rundreiseleiter in der Karibik verfäre
in der Karibik und da habe ich ganz gut
verdient und habe mir zwei Wohnungen
gekauft und von diesen zwei Wohnungen
von diesen Einnahmen lebe ich jetzt also
schon alleine von dem Mieteinnahmen
keine Steuern weil es nicht weil es
verboten ist aber sondern weil ich genau
unter diesem Satz bin was man zahlen
müsste versteinen was geht Ihnen bei
einer solchen Biographie durch den Kopf
jemand der sagt für mich ist Arbeit ja
lebenszeitverschwendung ich komme
wunderbar so durch ich habe zwei
Mietwohnung das passt naja wenn man zwei
Mietwohnungen hat und sich alles leisten
kann ist es ja nicht ganz so schlimm
aber ich glaube dass das dieser
Vorbildcharakter der hier entsteht ist
meiner sie nicht zuträglich gerade für
junge Leute die ja eigentlich ein Anreiz
haben er sagt es ja auch immer wir
müssen wieder Anreize schon wir müssen
das muss ein Ruck durch die Gesellschaft
gehen dass du Spaß hast an der Arbeit
ich meine keine Arbeit macht immer Spaß
auch die das Politiker möglicherweise
macht immer Spaß aber es ist so meistens
klar aber es ist doch so dass wir wieder
mal ein
selber aus dem Kragen herausziehen
müssen aus dem schlamasseln den wir
hängen und das können wir nicht nur über
hohe Gehälter ich glaube auch der
Fußballer weil wir ja bald wieder
Fußball sprechen der kriegt der läuft
mit 10 Millionen Gehalt nicht schneller
als mit einer Million Gehalt mach dir
das ein bisschen schlechtes Gewissen
weil die Wahrheit ist ja auch wenn wir
das alle so machen würden wie sie dann
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
natürlich
da bin ich leider anderer Meinung und
ich glaube auch die Tendenzen in der
Gesellschaft zeigen das ist auch so sein
wird und diese Tendenzen werden viel
gravierender sein als das Bürgergeld ja
es gibt eine vier Tage Woche das war so
Jugendliche für alle weniger arbeiten ja
die Leute wollen weniger arbeiten die
haben keine Lust mehr herstellen die
eine Karriere zu machen und alles für
die Karriere backt die Brötchen für Sie
wer backt das Brot für Sie wer macht die
Wurst für Sie wer kommt ins Haus um die
Handwerker arbeiten zu machen und und
und natürlich werden diese Arbeiten auch
gemacht aber wenn zum Beispiel Arbeiten
sind die nicht so toll sind die dürfen
dann vielleicht mehr bezahlt werden ja
aber es gibt natürlich man kann das
nicht globalisieren aber man kann es
nicht so für alle beschreiben es gibt ja
Leute die arbeiten gerne in ihrem Beruf
das sollen sie auch machen aber viele
und die Tendenz ist wirklich so dass
viele Leute nicht mehr arbeiten wollen
ja wir reden hier alle das war unbedingt
viel arbeiten müssen aber das stimmt
doch gar nicht schauen Sie mal also
das müsste bei Ihnen jetzt passieren
damit sie sozusagen auf der Zielgeraden
ihrer arbeitsbiografie noch mal sagen
Mensch ich gehe doch wieder arbeiten ich
komme sofort dazu aber ich muss mal eins
sagen also wir reden hier über
Bürgergeld ja und wir reden über Bürger
die das nötig haben vielleicht ja und
ich stehe zum Beispiel vom Arbeitsamt
und ich sehe die Leute ich sehe die
vielen Ukraine ja die teilweise sogar
Behinderte ankommen weil das zerschossen
worden sind und ich sehe auch noch
andere Fälle kann er jetzt mal sagen den
geht es wirklich nicht so gut ja und
darum geht es diesen Bürgern ein
vernünftiges Leben zu besorgen ja und da
sind wir jetzt gerade dabei bei jetzt wo
wir sie mit Herrn März gesprochen haben
oder so aber viele Leute haben überhaupt
keinen Empathie und noch Verständnis
aber dann gehen sie doch arbeiten und
zahlen Steuern und helfen Sie diesen
Sozialstaat zu finanzieren dann kommen
wir jetzt dazu das kann ich Ihnen gleich
sagen zu der Frage die sie gerade gesagt
die letzten zehn Jahre werde ich mit
Sicherheit nicht noch arbeiten ganz
ehrlich bestimmt
nicht das kann ich Ihnen ganz genauso
hier sagen und
was man da sowas was man jetzt so Moment
was man jetzt hier so gehört hat in der
ganzen Zeit ich wurde ja nicht so oft
gefragt aber eins ist klar ohne Arbeit
ist ein Mensch zweiter Klasse ja also
alle vier sind vollkommen der Meinung
man muss arbeiten und so stärker man
arbeitet umso mehr man arbeitet umso
toller Mensch dabei das hat kein
versuchen halt rauszubringen ich möchte
nur mal sagen in der Antike zum Beispiel
ja da war es genau umgekehrt ja da war
das Prestige so dass Leute die nicht
gearbeitet haben das waren wir können
das waren die intelligen könnten dann
allerdings sind Sozialstaat nicht
finanzieren das ist der Punkt das heißt
die Menschen die sie morgen arbeiten
[Musik]